>>Marcus: I'm slightly new to this.
I've not come to Google before.
So I'm guessing that given its 11 o'clock
and there are quite a few people here already
I'll just make a start.
So thank you for the invitation.
And I'm more than happy for you to ask me
questions as I go along.
It's a PowerPoint-based presentation, but
I'm gonna try to make it as engaging as possible.
And hopefully there'll be time at the end
for questions.
The title of the talk is, "Do I Look Happy
To You?"
And what I'm gonna talk about today is some
work that myself and a colleague of mine,
Ian Penton-Voak, at the University of Bristol
have been doing on the relationship between
how we see the world, how we see other people
in the world and how we interact with other
players in the world.
And social functioning, emotional functioning
and mental health.
So I'll talk a little bit about social cognition
and what that is.
And I'll talk about the relationship between
mental health and depression, with a particular
focus on two case studies where we've collected
some data that looks promising with respect
to how we might use this information to develop
new treatments for various mental health problems,
depression and aggression.
And then I'll talk about the future where
this kind of research might go and the extent
to which these kind of techniques in particular
lend themselves to the technologies that are
increasingly available to a large proportion
of the population, smart phones, tablets and
so on.
Part of the back story to this is that there
is growing interest in what has been described
as emotional intelligence, which is defined
in slightly different ways by different people.
But which relates very closely to this idea
of social cognition that I'm gonna be talk
about today.
This idea that the extent to which we encode,
store, retrieve, process information about
other people in the environment that we work
in that are members of the same species plays
a role in our ability to navigate the world
and to make sense of it.
So there's clearly a lot of interest in that,
and you can see from this "Emotional Intelligence
for Dummies" snapshot that much of the information
that we use when it comes to interacting with
other people is extracted from people's facial
expressions.
So the way that someone is looking at you
conveys considerable information in principle
at least that can guide the interactions that
we have with that person.
And so when there are biases, deficits, differences
in the way in which people do that those can
lead to differences in the ability of those
people to interact constructively or positively
with other people in their social world.
So for a long time we've known that there
are six primary or cardinal emotions.
Anger, fear, disgust, surprise, happiness
and sadness.
Which were very good at detecting, particularly
when you have people mugging those facial
expressions as you do here.
These pictures were taken from Paul Ekman's
work who was the individual who really created
this field and did the early work on these
primary emotions.
So hence the slightly dated look of the players
in the photographs.
But what's interesting about this is that
when you present these images cross culturally,
people are very good at detecting what emotion
is being expressed regardless of the specific
cultural context that they come from.
So for example, some early work that was done
with tribesmen in Papa New Guinea who had
had very little contact with the Western world,
in some cases almost no contact showed that
when you took photographs of individuals from
a Western society and showed them to individuals
from these tribes in Papa New Guinea, they
were very accurately able to extract the information
from those facial expressions and tell you
what emotion was being felt by that individual.
And when the same was done in reverse and
photographs were taken of those tribesmen
and taken back to Western societies people
in those Western societies were again very
able to accurately decode the information
that was being expressed in those faces.
So this seems to be a universal ability and
it seems to be to some extent relatively uncontaminated
by cultural specifics.
That's not to say that there isn't cultural
influence on the way in which we express ourselves
and the way in which we use nonverbal communication.
We know that that certainly is the case.
But when it comes the facial expressions of
emotion, these seem to be universal and relatively,
modestly influenced by cultural factors.
So here's an example of just how much information
is contained within facial expressions or
the face generally.
This is called the "Mind in the Eyes Test"
which has been produced by Simon Baron-Cohen
at the University of Cambridge.
And the question here is simply which of these
emotions do we think is being expressed in
this particular case.
So playful, comforting, irritated, bored.
And you can come to your own conclusions,
I won't ask people to stick their hands up
but most people would converge on that answer
to these eyes.
And in this case terrified, upset, arrogant
or annoyed.
When we're given a range of choices the majority
of people will choose that solution.
And so there are a range of these that we
can run and we can see that once you're given
a range of options, in particular then people
are reasonably accurate at identifying which
of those emotions is being expressed.
Even in a case where you only have the eyes
to extract that information from.
And clearly there's other information that
is expressed by other parts of the face.
And what's interesting is that there are certain
mental health problems or learning disabilities
that are associated with deficits in the ability
to do this.
So for example Autism Spectrum Disorder is
associated with a relative inability to correctly
identify which emotion is being expressed
in this mind in the eyes test.
And there are individual differences in the
healthy population as well which may or may
not relate to individual differences in for
example emotional intelligence.
But to give you an idea of some of the other
information that is expressed by faces, I'm
gonna show you two short video clips and the
question is, is the face that is moving male
or female?
I'm gonna have to come out of the PowerPoint
to do that in a moment.
But what you can see is that very basic shape
information has been extracted from these
faces and all you're going to see are points
of light which represent points on the face
moving as the person speaks.
So really distilling the information down
and the interface down to its most basic level.
So is the face male or female?
This is the first face; you may not want to
make a judgment until you've seen both.
That's the first face.
For some reason it's on a loop so it will
keep going unless I stop it.
And this is the second face.
The question is which of those faces is male
and which is female?
Would people feel able to make a judgment,
not necessarily with 100% confidence, but
with some degree of confidence just having
seen that movement information between the
two?
Which do you think was which?
>>Male 1: I think the second is female.
>>Marcus: You think the second is female?
Would most people agree with that?
That's certainly what most people say and
that's correct.
So even when you're only represented with
points of light representing points on the
face and the only information that's being
presented to you is the movements information
you are able to relatively accurately decode
rather that face is male or female.
And actually that's true when we look at gate
information when you show similar points of
light attached to joints on the body when
someone's walking across a room you can very
accurately decode whether that person is male
or female.
Whether or not that person is young or old
and so on.
So there's clearly a lot of information which
is conveyed nonverbally and much of that information
is conveyed by the face.
What's interesting is that there are differences
in how good people are at doing that.
Now the majority of what I'll be talking about
today will relate to various mental health
problems, low mood, aggressive behavior and
so on.
But there was a very interesting article published
a couple years ago showing that those from
wealthier backgrounds, those who enjoyed higher
social economic positions were actually worse
at these kinds of tasks than those from more
disadvantaged backgrounds or less wealthy
socioeconomic positions.
There's something about presumably the way
in which individuals are brought up in those
different structures of society which means
that those who are most affluent are actually
less able to accurately decode information
in faces and therefore less able to be empathically
accurate when making judgments about other
people and interacting with other people.
It's not clear from the observational data
what the direction of causation is, what causes
what.
But there clearly is a relationship and a
relationship that is perhaps counterintuitive
or a bit paradoxical.
But our interest has been primarily in the
relationship between the ability to decode
this information and our emotional well-being
and our mental health.
And actually if you look across a range of
mental health problems you'll see that there's
a very strong relationship between these and
the ability to decode emotional biases in
the extent to which ambiguous expressions
are interpreted as either positive or negative.
So for example in anxiety and depression there's
a tendency to be sensitive to negative emotions,
less sensitive to positive emotions.
In substance use there's a general deficit
in the ability to interpret emotions.
In conduct disorder there's a general tendency
to interpret ambiguity as hostile or reflecting
hostile intent.
Schizophrenia, autism also associated with
a general deficit in the ability to interpret
emotions.
So it's surprising how ubiquitous biases and
deficits in the ability to interpret emotions
are across a range of mental health problems.
And again it's not clear what the direction
of causation is.
For example in the case of substance use whether
that be alcoholism, heroin dependence or some
other form of substance use it may be the
chronic use of the drug is leading to changes
in your brain which means that you're less
able to decode this information.
But it's also possible that differences, if
you like, at baseline in the ability to successfully
navigate our social world because of these
deficits and the ability to interpret emotion
in others might lead to maladaptive coping
strategies like the use of alcohol to cope
with that inability to navigate the social
world.
So an important question here is, what comes
first and what is the causal relationship
between these information processing biases
and mental health?
So there are a range of different cognitive
biases that color the way in which we process
information in the world around us.
And the range of these have been described
in relation to different mental health problems.
So for example, attentional bias is a tendency
to pay attention to something which we think
is important at the expense of something which
may in fact be important.
In other words to focus our attention on things
which are particularly salient at this point
in time.
A good example of that is the cocktail party
affect where you'll be in a crowded room chatting
to someone who's in front of you and your
focus of attention will be on that person,
but then if you hear your name in the background,
babble of conversation that you weren't paying
attention to previously your attention shifts
towards that conversation because you've heard
your name.
And that phenomenon is well described.
Another example of attentional bias is that
if we walk down a street in the middle of
a night, we're very sensitive to the sound
of twigs cracking, shapes in bushes and that
kind of thing.
So the heightened arousal and anxiety that
we might feel in that situation focuses our
attention on certain things in a way that
it wouldn't do if we were just walking down
that same street in the middle of the day.
So attentional biases have been well described
in particular in relation to anxiety.
This tendency to focus on threat.
There are also memory biases, these are more
characteristic of depression that when we're
in a depressed state we're more likely to
remember negative autobiographical experiences.
Bad things that happen to us in the past tend
to dominate our thinking in a way that they
don't when were in a more positive frame of
mind.
And again the question is to what extent does
one cause the other?
And to what extent do individuals become trapped
in a vicious cycle once those memory biases
start to dominate so that you're always thinking
about negative events in the past.
And that tends to maintain your depressed
mood which in turn tends to maintain your
negative memory biases.
And what's interesting is that antidepressant
drugs which are effective for depression seem
to modify these cognitive biases.
So although these cognitive biases may play
a causal role, they may be modifiable.
And then there are also interpretive biases,
so here we have a sentence which can be interpreted
in a couple of different ways.
And depending in part on your personal history
but also in part on your mood state you can
either interpret that negatively or positively.
So the same sentence can be disambiguated
in a couple of different ways.
And the way in which you disambiguate that
sentence tends to correlate with your emotional
state.
And actually there's growing consensus that
drugs which are used to treat mental health
problems in particular like anxiety and depression
may in fact operate via these cognitive biases.
By directly changing those cognitive biases,
antidepressant drugs typically have to be
taken for a couple weeks before they begin
to have their affect.
And the perceived wisdom until recently was
that that is because of the need for downstream
changes in brain chemistry to occur once you
start taking the drug.
An alternative explanation is that these drugs
directly change the way in which you see the
world via these cognitive biases that I've
described.
But in order for that to have an impact on
your mood you need to start going out into
the world and interacting with people so that
that new way of seeing the world and that
new way of seeing other people in the world
leads to a change in your behavior towards
those people, and then a change in the behavior
that's reciprocated back to you from those
people so that you establish a virtuous cycle
where you're basically engaging more positively
in people in the world around you because
of this change in the way in which you see
the world and that then leads to improvements
in mood downstream of that.
But if that's true then of course another
possibility is to work directly on the cognitive
bias without any drugs, without any of pharmaceutical
therapy using purely behavioral techniques.
So that's what we've done.
Using faces that express varying degrees of
emotion.
So we have a sequence of faces which contain
more or less of a particular emotion or a
blend of different emotions.
So as you move along the sequence, that face
is reasonably ambiguous.
But as we begin to add a motion to that face,
by the time we get to the end of the sequence
it's relatively unambiguous.
Most people would say that that person was
sad.
And if we line up all the faces together you
can see that there is a gradual change.
And the point at which different individuals
begin to identify that emotion reliably gives
us a measure of that person's sensitivity
to that particular emotion.
And we can do the same with different blends
of emotion where the faces in the middle are
ambiguous and the question is which of the
two emotions that it contains dominates for
you in particular.
And the working model behind this is that
as observers of others in our social world,
when we see other people most of the time
people's facial expressions are ambiguous.
And so we need to overlay some interpretation
on that potentially ambiguous facial expression.
And the interpretation that we make if it's
negative will tend to sustain a vicious cycle
whereby if we think people are looking at
us in a particular way, if they are harboring
some hostile intent towards us for example
then we're going to respond appropriately
relative to what we think they're thinking.
But which may be inappropriate if that's not
what they're actually thinking.
Conversely if we can shift that initial attributional
bias, that interpretive bias so that these
ambiguous faces begin to be seen as more positive
on average then of course we can establish
a virtuous cycle whereby we start to see people
more positively.
Behave towards them more positively and we
would hope they would behave back towards
us more positively in return.
So what we're targeting here is the way in
which people see the world around them to
try and shift that in a positive and potentially
therapeutic direction.
So those are the questions, can we change
the way people perceive ambiguous expressions?
That's not trivial.
The ability to do that isn't a given and we
need to ask that question first.
But then if we can do that does that lead
to changes, improvements in behavior?
So the way in which we do this is using a
very simple computer task run off a laptop
or a tablet.
We've versions of this that run on smartphones
as well.
Where you present people with a screen that
they fixate on, so there's a fixation cross
just to make sure they're looking in the right
place.
Then very briefly, for 150 milliseconds we
present one of these faces along one of these
sequences that ranges from say neutral to
happy.
Or from sad to happy.
Then we mask that image to remove any visual
after affects so that the image doesn't hang
around for longer than the hundred and 150
milliseconds that we want it to.
And then we simply ask people to judge whether
that face is happy or angry say, or happy
or sad depending on the sequence of faces
that we use here.
And people can answer this in their own time.
And so what we get from that is a measure
of the points along the sequence at which
people stop seeing one emotion and begin seeing
another emotion.
So this particular sequence ranges from happy
to sad.
On the left-hand side you have an ambiguously
happy face, everyone says that's happy.
On the right-hand side you have an unambiguously
angry face, everyone says that angry.
In the middle you have this region of ambiguity
and there's a point at which an individual
will stop seeing one emotion and start seeing
another emotion.
And where that point is will differ across
individuals.
So we measure that point and then in a feedback
phase we run exactly the same kind of task
but we provide feedback based on that initial
threshold that we've measured.
The idea being that we can shift people so
that the faces that they previously said were
angry we say, that wasn't angry that was happy.
And we try to shift their threshold.
And we have a control condition, a comparison
condition where the feedback is designed to
keep their threshold the same.
And so all we're using his explicit feedback
to try and shift that threshold.
So what we end up with is someone who moves
from a particular threshold prior to training
which is the top panel.
To a different threshold after training which
is the bottom panel which is that this face
in the middle that was previously described
as angry is now described as happy.
So can we do this?
And can we do this in a way which is beneficial
for the well-being of the individuals concerned?
So in our first experiment, we looked at 80
otherwise healthy volunteers who had high
levels of depression symptoms.
We didn't select them on the basis of a clinical
diagnosis of depression, but about 70% of
them had levels of depression that would be
indicative of clinical depression.
Part the issue here is that a lot of people
suffer from depression but don't necessarily
seek support for it, don't necessarily go
to their GP for some kind of treatment.
So there's no real kind of unmet need for
these kind of symptoms to be addressed.
And we used a sequence that ranged from happy
to sad given prior evidence that depression
is associated with a relative sensitivity,
heightened sensitivity to sad facial expressions
and a reduced sensitivity to happily facial
expressions.
So the idea of the training was to shift the
point at which people stopped seeing happiness
and started seeing sadness to increase the
extent to which ambiguous expressions were
perceived as happy.
And people were randomized to one of two conditions.
In one condition their threshold wasn't shifted
it was kept the same and in the other condition
it was shifted in the way that I've described.
First of all, at baseline bearing in mind
that people differ in the point at which that
threshold occurs those with low mood were
more inclined to see sadness over happiness
than a controlled sample of individuals who
have normal levels of mood.
So this does seem to be to some extent predictive
of emotional state where you start from if
you like.
So you can regard this in some way as an attempt
to bring the low mood sample up to the point
where the healthy sample already are.
So the first question is can we do this?
Can we shift the way in which people interpret
emotional expressions in others?
And the answer is yes we can.
We ran the training over four consecutive
days.
The training lasted about 20 minutes.
The red bar represents the control group that
were given feedback designed to keep their
threshold the same.
And you can see that it doesn't change.
And those in the green bar were given feedback
that was designed to shift their threshold
and we can see that it did.
And most importantly although there was a
slight drop back every day from pre to post
testing and then to pretesting on the next
day, some of that shift that we'd achieved
during training carried over after they left
the lab if you like.
So they took some of that training away with
them out into that social world so that their
interactions with other people would be modified
by that change in which they were seeing other
people.
And by the end of the four days of training
there was quite a marked difference between
our control group and our training group.
So that answers the first question.
The second question is does it have an effect
on people's mood?
And the short answer is yes it does.
We measured people's mood before training,
immediately after training and then followed
them up two weeks later.
And in that two-week interim, they hadn't
done any more training, they were simply taking
the training that they had done over those
four days away with them if you like.
And we can see that at follow-up there was
a large and statistically significant difference
in the levels of positive mood reported by
those who had received the training compared
to those that were in the control condition.
So this training did seem to have a positive
impact on people's mood.
A second experiment that we ran was in a quite
different sample of individuals.
Adolescents aged 11 to 16 years old who were
referred to our youth program on the basis
of being at high risk of criminal offending.
About 70% of them had an official record of
criminal offending, stealing cars, dealing
drugs, antisocial behavior, aggressive behavior
and they were all screened to have high levels
of aggressive behavior.
So this is not a particularly easy to reach
group.
And certainly any behavior changes that we
can initiate in this group are likely to be
beneficial both to the individuals and to
society at large.
Here we use a slightly different sequence
of faces that range from happy to angry.
Again based on our prior literature that aggressive
behavior tends to be associated with an increased
attribution of hostility in other people.
And that's what we wanted to target.
We were able to change the perceptions of
emotional faces, ambiguous emotional faces
in exactly the same way as in the depression
study.
And we ran the training in exactly the same
way over four consecutive days with each session
lasting approximately 20 minutes.
And again people were randomized to either
be in a control condition or the training
condition.
And here we rated, asked participants to rate
their own aggressive behavior.
And they did that one week after training
and two weeks after training and you can see
that their own ratings of their own aggressive
behavior changed so that there was a decrease
in self-rated aggressive behavior in the training
condition relative to the control edition.
What was more exciting was that we also got
staff on the program who didn't know which
condition they'd been allocated to so they
weren't biased in their judgments on the basis
of knowing in advance which condition these
individuals had been placed in.
And there we showed that on the basis of those
independent ratings and behavior there was
a 30% decrease in aggressive behavior in the
training group compared to the control group.
And that persisted for up to two weeks after
the training ended.
And if anything the improvements strengthened
over time even after the training had ended
which is consistent with this idea that what
we're doing is subtly shifting the way in
which these people are seeing the world around
them and breaking them out of that vicious
cycle and putting them into a virtuous cycle
where they begin to interact more positively
with their wider social world.
Where do we go next with this?
We've got two studies which provide us with
very promising evidence that actually we can
shift the way in which people see others in
the world around them and do so in a way which
is therapeutic at least with respect to particularly
problems associated with those individuals
whether it be low mood or aggressive behavior.
We're looking at different ways of achieving
the same end.
The version of the training that I showed
you is one which is very explicit, you tell
people that wasn't a happy face, that was
a happy face.
And there's a question over to what extent
you're essentially leading people into responding
a certain way whether than genuinely changing
anything about their perceptions of people
in the world around them.
Now my view would be that while that may be
true for the healthy volunteers sample that
we recruited for the depression study it's
unlikely to be true for the 11 to 16-year-old
individuals who are at high risk of offending
simply because that's not the kind of population
that are simply going to do what you asked
him to do.
And if it was that simple then there wouldn't
need to be people like me doing this kind
of research we'd just tell them to behave
better and it doesn't work like that.
But we have been looking at other techniques
to achieve the same end.
And so what you see on the screen front of
you is what is described as "n-back" working
memory task where you're presented with a
series of faces sequentially on the screen
and the idea is to determine whether or not
the face that you're looking at is the same
as the one that appeared two faces back.
So you can see that as you move down from
top left to bottom right the second face that
appears also appears two frames later.
So when it appeared two frames later it'll
be a target because that face had appeared
two frames previously.
So you have to hold the information in your
working memory.
But what this is also doing is forcing you
to focus on the facial expressions.
And that means that we can make use of this
to implement what's called visual adaptation.
Now visual adaptation is something that you
can all experience if you have a waterfall
at hand or if you're traveling in a moving
vehicle.
It's the tendency for your brain to adapt
to consistent visual input and essentially
cancel that out.
So that when you look at something that doesn't
include that visual input, you get the reverse
effect.
So when you look at a waterfall for an extended
period and then you look away everything seems
to be drifting upwards.
Similarly when you're in a moving vehicle
and it works best if you're sat at the back
looking out back your visual field is moving
in one direction and when that vehicle comes
to a halt everything seems to creep back in
the opposite direction slightly.
You might be familiar with that affect, that's
visual adaptation.
And actually we can get visual adaptation
for facial features.
So if I were to show you lots of faces with
people's eyes very wide apart and then get
you to look at a normal face the eyes would
look very close together.
And that's visual adaptation.
But you can get visual adaptation effects
for emotional content in faces as well.
So if you look at lots of angry faces then
you look at a neutral face that neutral face
looks a little bit happier, a little bit more
positive.
So in a follow-up experiment, we did exactly
that.
Showing people using this kind of task where
they just have to focus on the faces being
presented on the screen either 50-50 happy
angry faces which wouldn't lead to any visual
adaptation or lots and lots of angry faces
which would lead to visual adaptation so that
neutral faces would be seen as more positive.
And then we got them to rate their mood.
And the group that had looked at lots of angry
faces reported feeling less angry.
Which is completely paradoxical but entirely
consistent with our earlier studies because
what we're doing is shifting that perception
so that neutral faces, ambiguous faces start
to be seen as more positive because of this
spatial adaptation affect.
So paradoxically, you look at lots of angry
faces you feel less angry in the context of
this specific study.
And there are lots of other things that we
can do with this.
So for example, we've run versions where instead
of modifying emotional content in faces we've
modified the extent to which a face is socially
dominant.
Social dominance is an important driver of
behavior in itself and there are characteristics
of faces which are correlated with drivers
of those behavior such as testosterone levels.
Essentially it's a masculinity transform.
So a socially dominant face is one with a
big jaw, solid eyebrows, that kind of thing.
And more submissive faces, one which is more
feminine in its characteristics.
And there's a lot of evidence that people
for example engaged in behavior economic tasks
will modify the deals that they engage in
based on perceived characteristics of the
person that they think they are making that
deal with.
And we can modify the way in which people
see others in the world around them using
that kind of information as well to make other
people look more or less socially dominant.
There are also other channels of information
that I haven't talked about today but which
are potentially important and which may add
context to the one channel of information
that I have been talking about, facial expressions
of emotion.
So here we can see for example a very nice
illustration of how exactly the same facial
expression can become disambiguated in different
ways depending on other contextual information
in this case postural information.
So I don't want to make claims that go too
far.
In that facial expressions while important
are only one channel of information and in
the real world, if you like, there are multiple
channels of information that are operating
in parallel and it's the combination of all
those which lead to us making our particular
judgment.
If we can change one of those, and that can
potentially have some impact.
But we would probably, if we wanted to do
a comprehensive job, work on multiple channels.
But there's a great deal of interest in the
extent to which these kinds of studies can
lead to intervention which could, in principle,
be delivered very easily, cheaply, remotely
via laptops, home computers, tablets, smart
phones and in particular tablets and smart
phones have an interface which lends itself
very well to this kind of interaction because
of the high quality screens and so on that
allow us to present the images that are central
to this, critical to these interventions,
in a very accessible and user-friendly way.
And this cartoon is taken from an article
in "The Economist" a couple years ago which
talked about the growing interest in computerized
interventions for well-being mental health
problems and so on.
So I'd just like to end by thanking all of
the funding councils that support this research
and for your patience in listening to me.
And I'm more than happy to answer any questions
that anyone might have at this stage.
And people might need to get away in which
case please feel free to, but if you have
a question please ask.
Yes.
>>Male 2: [Inaudible], it wasn't clear [inaudible]
>>Marcus: So the scales are somewhat arbitrary
in that they are for the most part questionnaire
measures or diary measures of behavior.
Which allow you to show relative change if
you like.
But in and of themselves don't necessarily
tell you whether or not that change is clinically
significant.
Certainly the magnitude of affect that we
observed in the young offenders was sufficiently
large, but it would almost certainly be beneficial
if it scaled up.
If it were shown to be a reliable affect that
was persistent, then that would be a change
that would be valuable.
The change in positive mood that was identified
in the depression study is of an order of
magnitude that would be consistent with people
actually subjectively feeling better in themselves.
But we're running a larger scale follow-up
at the moment just to confirm that when we
see these changes in how people complete questionnaires
about their mood it actually maps onto how
they feel in themselves and whether they feel
better.
>>Male 3: [inaudible]
>>Marcus: No, were doing a follow-up study
which is a new group of people where we'll
follow them up for a longer period and take
more comprehensive measures.
>>Male 3: [inaudible]
>>Marcus: No, no that was just a pilot study
essentially to establish the proof of principle.
It looked very encouraging.
Two weeks is a reasonably long time given
that they're not doing anything in between.
So to show an improvement in mood that persists
for that length of time is certainly encouraging.
But you are right we need to do this more
comprehensively just to establish in principle
that these improvements, if they're reliable,
are clinically significant and actually make
a difference to how people feel in themselves
which is ultimately what it boils down to.
>>Male 4: So do you see a scenario where doctors
[inaudible]
>>Marcus: Potentially.
I mean we're moving in that direction already.
So for example cognitive behavioral therapy
is the psychological therapy of choice within
the national health services at the moment.
But it can be very expensive to deliver because
it requires one to one time with a therapist
who is trained in that skill.
There are computerized versions of cognitive
behavioral therapy which are increasingly
being recommended because they're highly cost-effective
as long as people engage with them adequately.
Now the problem with a lot of computerized
cognitive behavioral therapy is that it's
quite demanding, quite time-consuming.
You have to go away and do homework and come
back to it and so on.
So there's probably a place in conjunction
with that for something which is more rapid
and targeted of the kind that I've described.
But absolutely I think increasingly that will
be the way in which several healthcare services
are delivered.
And the NHS already has a number of apps that
you can use to monitor various health behaviors.
>>Male 5: So all of your participants, all
the training can be in a controlled environment.
[Inaudible]?
>>Marcus: No we didn't exclude people on the
basis of antidepressant medication, but because
only I think about 30% actually had a clinical
diagnosis.
The majority weren't taking any form of treatment
at the time.
Again in our follow-up study, we are being
slightly more stringent about our inclusion
and exclusion criteria just to select people
that aren't taking antidepressant medication
simply because those pharmaceutical therapies
as I mentioned at the beginning have been
shown in themselves to modify these kinds
of biases.
So it could potentially contaminate our results
somewhat.
>>Male 6: [Inaudible] Research on how people
feel in different social cultures.
I mean, there is American culture [inaudible]
and European culture where people are more
serious, so how individuals feel in those
cultures themselves and [inaudible]
>>Marcus: That's a really good question.
I am not aware of any research on that which
isn't to say that it hasn't been done but
just that I'm not aware of it.
But you could absolutely see how that could
be the case because actually having lived
in different countries myself often it's the
mismatch between your sort of expectation
and the way in which you're interpreting what's
going on around you and what other people
are thinking and doing and expecting you to
take from that interaction that can be the
problem.
So you could see that if there were differences
in the way that information was expressed
by one individual that didn't translate to
a different culture then that could certainly
lead to problems when it came to feeling comfortable
in that culture.
And that wouldn't surprise me at all.
Like I say, I'm not aware of any research
that looks at that explicitly, but I certainly
would expect that to play part.
>>Male 7: The sequence of faces, how do you
create it?
>>Marcus: So the person, so to speak, is not
a real person but it's a composite of multiple
faces so that it is like an average person.
So there's nothing particularly distinctive
about him and we have female versions as well.
So any really unusual characteristic is essentially
smoothed out by blending you know 5, 6, 7
or more different faces to create this average
composite.
Then you create composites for people who
are giving you a blank expression, have a
neutral expression and then you ask those
people to also mug happiness, sadness and
just express the different cardinal emotions
that I mentioned.
So you create composites for neutral and for
each of the different emotions.
And then you create, blend between those just
using morphing techniques, computer graphic
morphing techniques which are very well established
so that the faces in the middle contained
some proportion of a particular emotion or
a blend of two different emotions.
>>Male 8: [Inaudible]
>>Marcus: [laughs] To look very slightly sad
or very slightly happy.
No we just get the computer to do it, they're
much more reliable that way.
Actually we do find that there are individual
differences in how good people are at sort
of faking an expression which is perhaps not
surprising.
That in itself might be interesting.
And one of the questions that we haven't addressed
yet but which may be relevant here is the
extent to which people, we're talking about
the way in which you perceive emotions in
others.
But of course it's also important the extent
to which you express emotions yourself.
We know that depression is associated with
the relative blunting of the ability to express
different emotions.
And that may be something which is playing
a role too, and may be something which is
potentially trainable as well.
>>Male 9: [Inaudible]
>>Marcus: We have done a small pilot study
in a school in Somerset with children with
Autism Spectrum Disorder where we used, we
just chose one emotion happiness because there's
nothing problematic about people becoming
more sensitive to happy, you would imagine
that be a good thing.
So the sequence that we used ran from neutral
to happy.
And we were just interested in whether we
could shift that threshold to make them more
sensitive to these low levels of emotional
expression.
What was interesting there is that, you know
many of these kids have quite serious learning
disabilities and some of those were motor
in nature so they weren't actually able to
press the buttons on the keyboard of the laptop
that was running the tasks.
So often the experimenter had to actually
press the buttons.
But we still saw a change in the threshold
which was quite reliable.
So we were able to change their sensitivity
to these emotions in the context of the task.
We haven't yet looked at any behavioral consequences
of that, whether that improves the social
functioning.
But we've got a project starting on that in
the autumn.
And we're going to be running a similar project
in adults with Autism Spectrum Disorders well.
>>Male 10: [Inaudible]
>>Marcus: Yes.
So I mean as primates we are sort of inherently
hierarchical.
And the difficulty in modern societies is
that it's not always clear what that hierarchy
is.
But one of the signals that we use to determine
someone's place in the dominance hierarchy
is to just simply how they look.
And that could include facial features.
And so there's quite a literature on the extent
to which different faces are judged as more
or less dominant depending on essentially
the masculinity of their facial features.
And there's some evidence now which is emerging
which suggests that the way in which those
people are interacted with, particularly in
the behavior economic games which are known
to be influenced by things like testosterone
levels and so on can be modified by the perception
of the person that you think you're interacting
with.
>>Male 11: [Inaudible]
>>Marcus: I'm not sure if that's been looked
at terribly closely.
Because you have lots of other factors that
come into play when you have males interacting
with males, males interacting with females,
females interacting with females and so on.
So it becomes very complicated very quickly.
So I wouldn't want to say that it's as simple
as because of these facial features being
associated typically with masculinity that
therefore there are going to be differences
in those interactions.
But it's a possibility and that's an empirical
question we could find that out.
All right in that case, thank you very much
for your time and your patience.
And I hope that you found that reasonably
interesting.
[applause]